Speaker 1: Donald Trump faces 33 years in
prison.
For just what the DOJ is investigating him
for, as well as the loss of his ability to
hold public office.
That is the maximum possible penalty for Donald
Trump based on what he is being investigated
for.
There are basically three elements to this,
and we're going to look at each of them.
You've got the Espionage Act.
If Trump is found guilty of violating the
Espionage Act, he would pay face fines and
up to ten years in prison.
Now, the search warrant from Friday cites
18 U.S. Code 793.
That's a part of the Espionage Act, which
refers to the, quote, gathering, transmitting
or losing defense information.
Some of the stock.
The documents reportedly relate to nuclear
weapons.
So if charged for that violation, Trump could
be looking at fines and up to ten years in
prison.
Part two of this investigation in connection
with the FBI's search warrant served at Mar
a Lago is concealment of documents there.
We are looking at possible fines and up to
three years in prison.
The warrant points to 18 U.S. Code 2071.
That's on the, quote, concealment, removal
or mutilation generally.
And based on that provision, it is illegal
to take government documents.
It makes it a crime for anyone to have any
federal record in their possession with the
intent to either conceal or destroy.
So if charged there, if convicted, trumps
looking at a fine or three years in prison.
But very importantly and this is why 2071
has been a big deal over the last few days.
If Trump is found guilty there, he could be
disqualified from holding any public office
in the future.
Could be very relevant in 2024.
And then the third element here is obstruction
of justice, possible fines, and up to 20 years
in prison.
Admittedly, most people don't get 20 years
for obstruction of justice, but that would
be 18 U.S. Code 1519 that deals with the,
quote, destruction, alteration or falsification
of records in federal investigations and bankruptcy.
You are also forbidden from destroying federal
records, and this is the highest potential
sentence, the 20 year sentence and fines are
relatively modest.
Now, we are many, many steps from anybody
talking about prison time, but this is if
we're if the question is being asked, what
is the most that we could be looking at for
what the DOJ is investigating?
Remember, there's the Georgia investigation.
There's all these other things.
Forget about that.
Just for what DOJ is investigating.
If Trump was found guilty in all three of
these areas, if he got the stiffest sentence,
and if the sentences ran consecutively rather
than concurrently, you could be looking at
33 years fines and loss of ability disqualification
from holding public office.
Is it likely that we would ever get to that?
The answer is no, but the next step would
be indictment.
Then you would have a trial slash plea if
you get guilty verdicts.
Then you have sentencing appeals.
So this is a very, very long road.
But at the end of this path, the absolute
maximum would be that the 33 years fines can't
run for public office.
If you believe Trump will ever see anything
like that or even a day behind prison bars,
let me know.
I still don't see it.
Want to let everybody know?
Wednesday, August 31st, we will be doing our
members only town hall.
This is a member benefit that we used to do
more regularly.
We got away from it.
We've done a bunch of regular town halls.
Wednesday, October, August 31st at 6 p.m.
Eastern, 3 p.m. Pacific.
We will be doing a member's only town hall
opening the phone lines to our website members.
If you'd like to participate.
Among all the other great member benefits
that there are, you can sign up at join Packman
dot com.
More on that later and in the week's upcoming.